I'm joined by Susie Boniface and Henry
Hill great to see you this Friday
evening thanks for joining us let's
start with Donald Trump shall we Susie
the financial times Trump to turn
himself in as indictment rocks U.S
politics uh it's believed he'll head to
New York on Monday he'll appear in court
on Tuesday but we don't think he's going
to be handcuffed although he will have a
mug shot taken
yes we don't know um if they're going to
have a fingerprint form small enough for
his tiny hands to put his little dabs on
either
um it's kind of interesting what's going
to happen here so first off you've got
someone who is a fantastic
self-publishist who just spouts stuff
off all the time and loves the attention
who's going to be at the center of all
that attention and he's going to love
that and he's going to be sucking
um attention and power out of if you
like everything else that might be
happening in the news in America or
anywhere else around the world so people
aren't going to be noticing what Joe
Biden's up to that day for example
um but at the same time he's being
noticed for something that's not
particularly favorable to him so it's
he's talking about this being a Witch
Hunt which is sort of Madness because
witches were accused of doing things
that were impossible whereas Donald
Trump's been accused of doing something
which the courts have already accepted
happened
um he did pay 130 000 to Stormy Daniels
to stop her talking about
um their Affair uh which he says didn't
happen but he admits that the payment
happened and he admits that his lawyer
did it and the court has agreed that his
lawyer did that when his lawyer was
sentenced for doing exactly that a
couple of years ago but what this is is
really what's difficult here is that
this is a really untested part almost of
the the US sort of legal system in the
estate New York is putting him on trial
for doing something which would have
been if it's proven a campaign Finance
violation that will have affected
something on a federal level and the New
York laws aren't designed for that it's
completely untested and theoretical so
it's possible that he may find some
regular room to get out of it but what
comes right down to the bottom of all of
this okay which is that fundamental
thing that payment to Stormy Daniels
number one it was completely unnecessary
because the fact that he was a
womanizing uh liar was pretty much baked
into everyone who voted for Trump in the
same way that it was with Boris Johnson
so he didn't really need to pay her off
at all and number two is the fact that
in order to pay her to shut her up what
he actually did was guarantee that she
was going to be speaking to every news
Outlet whoever asked her a question ever
again so it didn't work the whole thing
was fundamentally stupid idea and it's
this which is causing all his problems
it's not the fact that he had an affair
it's not the fact that he's paid someone
off it's the fact he's trying to cover
up and hide something that he should
have just been open about at the start
and it wouldn't matter now we wouldn't
be facing all this but because he wanted
to try and pretend that you know he
didn't have his hand in the cookie jar
is where why we are where we are because
maybe two years yeah and and Henry
inside the mirror uh it explains uh the
case against him I mean you you've
surprised this has come to trial I mean
it's the weakest case isn't it out of
all the potential cases that he faces
I mean I I think being surprised would
imply that I have more knowledge of the
US legal system than I'm going to
protect that I'm going to pretend that I
have right but yeah I mean they got but
they got our Al Capone on tax evasion uh
so there's a fine U.S history of getting
people online charges and I think it's
interesting what Susie says about maybe
Trump being able to wriggle out of the
New York charges because they have a
federal Dimension that might be
announced at the frying pan Into the
Fire moment for him because if I were up
on state charges which carry relatively
limited uh prison terms I wouldn't
necessarily want my lawyer to get me off
it by going actually your honor I should
be facing federal charges because you
know you can you can be sure that those
federal charges would be coming down the
track but but yes of all of the cases
that you could make against Trump as
Susie was saying this is an untested
case it basically requires
various different bits of New York state
law to interact in a certain way and and
they're not that they have not
interacted that way before so it's going
to be for the court to determine
basically whether what Trump did or what
Trump lawyers did was actually illegal
in the way the prosecution is alleging
um from each of the times carrying the
story as well they're going with that
angle that uh he is going to refuse to
be handcuffed
um I mean Susie do you think there is
some political motivation here just
listening to what Nancy Pelosi said
today she said he'll have the chance to
prove his innocence but that's not how
democracy and the judicial system works
is it you're innocent until you're
proven guilty
yes um and if you are you know acquitted
of something and we don't know what the
possible verdict would be then you know
things can look a bit different but the
chances are this is probably going to
run on until 2024 which would mean he
would be right in the middle of the next
presidential race
we're at the stage at the moment where
um he wants to get the Republican
nomination to run again we don't know
that he definitely would but he would
arguably split his party and perhaps
some of the Republican vote uh if he
were to try that
um and then there's the fact of course
that in the U.S Constitution you having
been convicted of a criminal offense
doesn't automatically buy you from being
president and so they do have the
possibility that not only will he be you
know a criminal ex-president he could be
the next president as well and yet still
have a criminal record hanging around
his neck but even if he manages to
wriggle his way out of this even if he's
convicted of It kind of almost
irrelevant because he's also still
facing an investigation into vote
rigging in Georgia he's still facing um
investigation into what happened when he
was encouraging the Capitol Hill riots
in 2021
um and I think there's another one as
well that's uh about financial stuff
which and his documentation and so on
which is still ongoing some of which
carry 5 are far more severe penalties so
you know this isn't going away any of it
and of course we've seen elsewhere
tonight as well that the Dominion
lawsuit but from the company that
operates those electoral counting
machines
which were said by Fox News to have uh
somehow rigged the last presidential
election they've got a 1.6 billion
dollar defamation case against Fox which
is going to court as well so that
everything that kind of comes in around
the end of Trump's time and power all
that sort of chaotic last year of the
accusations and the counterclaims and
the misinformation it's all starting to
unravel a bit but it's going to unravel
for a very long period of time it's not
going to happen quickly and it's almost
certainly going to influence and affect
the next presidential race even if he's
not in it yeah well let's talk about
that shall we the front page of the
Daily Star Henry quite a lot going on
there The bigly Unusual Suspect a
mock-up there of of his mug shot I guess
and as we were hearing it's going to be
drawn out but it's certainly going to
fire up his base isn't it the polls are
suggesting that this whole case could
well work in his favor especially when
it comes to the Republican nomination
potentially and I certainly think that
if you're in an environment as polarized
as America you do want to avoid making
it sound as if you're using state or
federal prosecutors in a political way
so I'm not entirely sure that Nazi
Pelosi's uh intervention was helpful I
it really depends I suppose how the case
goes because yes on the one hand he can
play the victim card but on the other
hand if this just ends up being a
Relentless day after day week after week
series of terrible headlines of evidence
of this or that that's not the best case
that's not the best that Suite of
weapons in which to go into a primary
season when you're running against the
likely Contender Governor or DeSantis of
Florida now what DeSantis is doing
whether you agree or disagree with him
and most people in Britain aren't going
to particularly like descendants if he
becomes president let's be honest but he
is racking up achievement after
achievement after achievement after
achievement and he is aiming at those
conservative voters who Trump has tried
to peel away and make the basis of his
claim on the Republican party so so yes
he could he could play this to his
Advantage it's definitely not Beyond
someone as Shameless As Trump but I
think if you're thinking about the next
year ahead of the head of the general
then on the one hand you have Trump
sleazy charged Suzy charge victimhood on
the other hand you have the santis this
law that law the other law I think it
might not be uh as good for Trump as
some pessimists think it is okay all
eyes on New York on Tuesday uh let's
turn our attention to matters closer to
home uh front of the daily mail at last
deal to turbocharge brexit Britain
um Susie this is uh this is good news
isn't it joining the indo-pacific trade
block
well the government would like us to
think so and that the mail and the
express uh the sort of conservative
Middle Market papers also want us to
think so saying this is a great boost
and so on they're very much repeating
the the government line without much
criticism which is that uh this is an
emerging trading block it's going to be
bigger and uh more uh worth more more to
us in the long run than the EU is uh and
that we're in on the ground floor and we
can influence how it develops um the
criticism of that is that at the moment
it's not looking like it's going to make
us a lot of money anytime soon also that
China is going to be trying to join it
fairly quickly uh and Liz truss is
sticking her or in saying that we
shouldn't let China join a trading
partnership which is about the Pacific
which was we are nowhere near but China
is next door to
um and then there's of course the
argument of course well it's very well
saying you're joining a new trading
partnership and so on but it is on the
other side of the planet and we have a
trading partnership but we did we with
our nearest neighbor the EU and we
should be spending quite a bit of time
you'd have thought concentrating on that
because it's much easier and cheaper to
trade with someone next to you than it
is to trade Halfway Around the other
side of the world
same story on the front of the express
Henry
yeah I mean I suppose the line uh from
the government is that basically the
yeah the cttp I can I may have got those
letters wrong I get them wrong every
time I say them um is is is farther away
from the European Union uh the trading
volume is lower than Dart trading volume
with the EU it may be a growth sector
and it will probably profit us to be a
hit and that's all fine I think the
argument via V the EU is that the
problem with the EU from the British
perspective even from lots of people who
wanted to stay in it is that the EU is
not just the trading block it has never
been just a trading block it has
perfectly legitimate aspirations to be
more than that towards political union
that's why it has things like a
parliament and and so on and basically
that is a big if you like sovereignty
tariff that you have to pay to join the
EU which you don't have to pay to be a
member of ctpp uh so that's the
trade-off for the government it's not
necessarily worth quite the same amount
in sort of bonus to GDP terms at least
not originally but it involves far fewer
trade-offs with regards to democratic
self-government and all the rest of it
but I think frankly it is important to
remember whenever we're talking about
this kind of story The the impact of any
of these deals are day-to-day lives is
in terms of the amount of money extra
money it will make for Britain is small
right we're not going to be immediately
walking around in a couple of years
feeling very tangibly richer because
we've joined any one or the other of
these blocks yeah can we about not the
the trace secretary saying it's a bit
like buying a startup we're thinking
about the uh the potential looking ahead
um all right we'll leave that one there
thank you both for the moment coming up
after the break we've already talked
about one American president next we're
going to turn to Joe Biden and why he
won't be coming to the coronation back
in a moment
[Music]
thank you
part two of The Press preview Susie and
Henry are still with us
um Susie let's have a look at the front
of the Daily Telegraph only the
telegraph front page reporting this
actually
um they seem to have got this first um
Joe Biden won't be coming to the
coronation but it's not a snub we're
being told
no well who knows quite where this is
coming from it could have been coming
from the palace it could be coming from
the government it could be coming from
uh someone uh inside uh the capital even
but it does seem that although the heads
of state various places will all have
been invited that this particular one
has decided uh he needs a bit of a rest
and doesn't want to come who knows why
it could well be he's got he's going to
be over here anyway for uh Northern
Ireland the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement and maybe he doesn't
want to do that trip twice in the space
of a few weeks he is knocking on a bit
and he's going to need a bit of a break
you know one one big long transatlantic
flight is enough for anybody in their
80s really have you got to do two in a
month it's probably a bit much I'd have
thought yeah and Henry is going to send
a delegation including I think Jill
Biden
so so it's so it's it hinted I don't
there's no there's nothing definite in
the daily in the Daily Telegraph story
just says that he's uh thinking about
sending a delegation that will include
his wife and the best spin you the case
you could make for this is that yes
currently I believe he's attending to uh
visit Northern Ireland for the course
Centenary of the Belfast agreement
although that was always dependent on
Stormont being back up and running which
as of now it won't be so we don't
entirely know that's true but
nonetheless this is a major world event
uh heads of state from all over the
world are attending we only do these
coronations I think yeah the last one
was 60 70 years ago so it's a very long
time uh or at least a very long time ago
so it will be taken as a snob in some
quarters uh now he is getting on
obviously he has Air Force One so I
don't think that his transplanting
flights to fight is trying as they might
be for you or I but nonetheless I don't
think it's a hugely significant blow to
Britain's Prestige if you like but I do
hope there's something in the Daily
Telegraph story about a threat to the
special relationship I do hope that this
kind of thing just kind of wakes some
especially some conservatives up a bit
about the fact that the special
relationship it always does sound a bit
needy and delusional um and this kind of
illustrates that point quite well okay
uh let's turn our attention to in front
of the Guardian I mean this is this is
this is pretty damning isn't it uh Susie
raw sewage
um poured into English rivers 825 times
a day last year
yep 300 000 times in total over the
course of the year uh and interestingly
you know some of the most worst affected
places I think the front of the
telegraph as well as reporting it it's
talking about places like meirsfield in
East Sussex which is very true blue Tory
area the guardian here is talking about
Therese coffee the environment secretary
but you know she should be resigning
because of the state of uh Britain's
waterways and also I think it's the
times it might be the telegraph is
talking about
um some tougher you know sanctions on
water companies which is very much the
government end of things but it's just
it's just a case of making the the fines
a bit bigger there's nothing really
meaty in terms of making it a crime
perhaps to to um to pollute a Waterway
with raw sewage there's nothing about
forcing these uh mostly foreign owned
water companies to actually invest a lot
of their profits in repairing the
systems which need to be made ready and
more resilient for the effects of
climate change and increased flooding
and things like that
um so it's very much I mean it's it's
the kind of thing that's super appalling
that's gonna affect a lot and annoy a
lot of conservative voters and yet the
conservative government doesn't see the
need to be as tough about this about our
rivers and our water and our everything
else and our seas and our beach
qualities they don't see the reason to
be as tough about this as they are about
graffiti for example as they have done
over the past week I think they've
misjudged this this is going to really
um come back to bite at the time of the
next election yeah and especially with
the with the local elections around the
corner as well um and let's finish with
this story on the front of the mirror
Henry
um and this you know this is a nice a
nice story to end on really um some good
out of the tragic death of Paul O'Grady
yeah uh absolutely basically the in in
the wake of Paul's death the huge
numbers of people have uh decided to
donate to basic dogs and cats with which
he had a long-standing Association and
it is always lovely when a tragedy like
this you often when we're dealing with
the news especially when you're dealing
with politics you do see a lot of the
very worst of of written and bits of
this country and how people behave and
sometimes it's just really nice to see a
prominent news story which is actually
just showcasing the very best of us you
know the fact that so many people have
given and the fact that somebody lived
life which inspired so many people to
give yeah well said the chief executive
of the uh battery dogs and cats home
saying we're overwhelmed and touched
thank you both